hello everyone we got it to work great
news
um hi i'm playing flight simulator uh
i can't play this for very long i was
gonna do it last night but it's
so hot in my apartment right now that
even
being near my pc is a massive problem
um it's awful but
i've been really excited about this game
or simulator um
and i ha i don't care about flight
simulators at all so it's like
kind of weird that i'm even excited
about it so i was like i'm just gonna do
a quick flight we'll check it out
um i could probably do like half an hour
before i melt because
my air conditioner doesn't work it's
just the worst um
so let's do it this is my first time
playing it i wanted it to be fresh i'm
probably gonna be really bad at this
like i said
i don't know anything about flight sims
i've never cared before
the realism of this one just really got
me and i also think that um
the fact that i can kind of go home in a
time where i really wish i could go back
to australia
like it just appeals to me a lot so
let's do it
um yeah i'm running on medium settings i
have satellite streaming on
um just for anyone who's wondering so
okay
i'm gonna go from lax
it doesn't work that way do i have to
click search
uh okay then let's go los angeles
no get give me
ellie give me la how does this
how does this function why are we in
s-c-g-e it's
k-l-a-x you tell me okay k-l-a-x
there we go weird that the search
function doesn't work as well as i would
expect all right
um some arrival airport i'm gonna be any
that's gonna be ybn brisbane
international okay that's what i want to
do take me home
um
i think that's it i mean i don't really
care about the time
i don't know what any of this means
let's just fly
i'm using a controller with mouse and
keyboard it seems
you have to do both that's what
microsoft suggested uh obviously i don't
have a flight stick again
not traditionally a flight sim person
so i guess we'll see
but yeah just thought i would quickly
like check it out because it looks so
freaking pretty and i've been stoked
about it uh this could be a total
disaster
yeah buffkinsmith it took me a really
long time to download too i also had to
close the game and open it again because
it got stuck on a loading screen um and
i've seen like maybe four people say the
same thing
jonas i'm playing on medium graphic
settings for this game
uh specifically i probably could do
something more extreme but
we decided to just go
medium i think lax to brisbane is longer
than 11 hours did it say 11 ounce
might be didn't i um
i am going to be joining uh bruce green
later on his stream where they're
currently doing like i think it's like
an 18-hour flight so i'm gonna be
heading there
for that i know there are a lot of ways
to simulate things like speed it up
because i don't really want to do this
flight in real time
loading screens i saw the reviews
mentioned that they're really bad
this is definitely already a thing like
even getting into the main menu the
loading screens are atrocious
but i suppose it's a big game but still
yeah real slow real slow
they crashed on that stream i could
crash right now
i again i really don't know what i'm
doing i just want to preface that
aggressively you can't say i don't know
what i'm doing
i already said it
how hot is it here right now um it's 41
right now which is
probably in fahrenheit maybe like 110
but my apartment is hotter than the
outside so i feel like
inside of my apartment again when i'm
sitting at my pc it feels like it's a
heater
um and it's just been so awful it's
probably more like 50 degrees in here
celsius which is like i don't know 130
maybe i really don't know
um no garrett don't have a flight stick
because i don't own one
just have a controller um yeah not a
not a flight stick person
come on buddy play video game
yeah i'm struggling you guys trust me
i'm struggling
again it's hotter in my apartment than
outside outside is saying 40 degrees
i am melting it's also just permanently
put me in a terrible mood
i am sweating buckets when i got up off
my seat yesterday there was a butt
imprint of sweat
like it's so bad hence
i can't really stream right now not
gonna stream forward x-ray golf sierra
alpha and runway two fife
ready for takeoff departure to the west
take off departure to the west
we are going to fly a plane
i don't know what any of this means
should i move my webcam maybe
like should i
two fight right perhaps or golf sierra i
am clear today for a runway
you sound so funny let me make sure that
i have it cropped i
do i don't know if this is the right
place to put the webcam let's keep the
game there and then just like
maybe put me over here and we can swap
it back if we need to
okay what could go wrong
i don't even know the controls there's
been no tutorial
parking braking gauge okay yeah of
course i have to do that
did i yep okay now what um
oh this is so
i can just imagine that flight sim nerds
are like all very
excited about this uh like
even looking at it i'm like yes this
seems elaborate i don't know what's
happening okay throttle control to
increase engine power gradually press
and hold
the throttle i think that's where is
that going to be on my controller
is that going to be not sure
didn't tell me the controls a b for
throttle did it say that
okay
pushing a b that seems wrong a
okay it's just a it's just a all right
we got it we got it
i don't feel like i'm ready for this you
know i don't feel like i have any idea
what i'm doing
it hasn't told me anything
oh oh oh the plane is is oh oh okay
okay okay
this what a bumpy takeoff we've had okay
i'm gonna try and even out
retract landing gear press left stick
cute
all right yep seems good i'm in the air
so that's cool
oh okay okay okay press f5 did it i
retracted my flaps
frequency i am leaving your airspace
frequency oh i need to change root is
that what you just told me sir
i don't know to reduce speed your
incline pitch the nose up slightly by
pressing
yep sure okay oh am i going too fast is
what you're telling
me
hmm this is very elaborate oh
boy uh-oh uh-oh came for us
and i don't really want to fly across
the ocean this whole way
um because that really is a lot of what
this flight
is is just
the pacific ocean what did you tell me
to do
i don't know how to talk to you sir
something is beeping we're going to die
spinning and i didn't mean to be
spinning
holy [ __ ] to increase speed you're
inclined pitch the nose down slightly
okay oh [ __ ]
oh my god
stalled in the sky pull up
pull up got it nope nope didn't nope
nope okay we're gonna go do the tutorial
i thought that it would be
press play and then it would give me a
tutorial turns out it didn't
apparently it's in the main menu
somewhere
things are off to a bad start i just
want to go to brisbane
you know
that was uh i didn't even know what
happened it just [ __ ] it just
happened it just
really took on a life of its own
who knows who i didn't even hear what i
was doing wrong
okay that's a live event flight training
but i don't even want to do the flight
training i just want to go to brisbane
that's probably it though right
or is it gonna be that
i feel like flight training is probably
the right call [ __ ] this is a lot of
tutorial
okay sure yeah let's do basic controls
and cameras all right
that's chill sure get to know your
aircraft environment this training
session will from your arrangement
explode okay sure right
seems fine
you're absolutely right coast guard i
just want to go home and see my family i
just want to go to brisbane
every time that i ever land in brisbane
the uh planes i guess it's actually not
every time um but you can often see the
entire city like this beautiful of a
view of the city
and uh literally every time i'll like
look out the window and just stop crying
oh my god
it's very nice he was telling me to
change frequency to a different air
traffic control station oh
well i mean that doesn't really help me
that much
daniel anyway because i wouldn't have
known how to do it regardless
so they could tell me that and i
wouldn't have known how to do it anyway
so who knows
it's not too hot to run my computer my
my computer is uh
i i have liquid cooling so yeah my
computer is okay it's just
very [ __ ] uncomfortable for me
can you jump out i don't believe so
well i didn't try to fly straight down
but it kept telling me to dip the nose
because i was
too fast or something it kept being like
you should dip that nose
you need to slow down so i did that and
then i did start going down i think
maybe
i'm gonna turn the music up tell me if
that's too loud it's a really nice song
then
it's really hot and i've already been
streaming for 12 minutes and we're just
loading the tutorial
this isn't gonna work out the way that i
planned
because the loading screens are really
well they're really [ __ ] long
and the game is understandably
quite difficult okay great am i ready
i guess we'll find out oh i'm already
flying oh welcome to play training it's
not me
where is the instructor captain molina
you say that but where are they just
call me jess
okay this session we'll get started with
some basic controls
sound good cool first things first
let's get familiar with your
surroundings
don't worry i've got the stick while you
get your bearings
basic controls is ctrl c out your
that's not what i wanted at all okay um
this is red rock territory beautiful
isn't it
it doesn't look that good uh
i'm sure if i were there in post it
would look nice but those textures don't
look that great um
we are streaming from satellite that is
the option that i chose
okay yeah familiar with how to use a
camera
uh aircraft views is not my biggest
concern
flying the [ __ ] plane is but yeah no
this looks it looks a bit muddy really
um yep okay what now
left uh you want me to do it here up
down front
is what you wanted
do i have to do it just more extensively
the details on the plane oh my god i've
just spun my head around in a circle
keyboard arrows okay i can do that
you're right it is keyboard arrows for
some reason
uh save a custom camera
back to pilot view is alt one
see if you can spot the sedona airport
the runway should be a pretty easy
landmark to find
oh wow [ __ ] that is cool
so i guess it's that this game is a
strange mix
of needing to use your mouse and even
the user controller um
wow
yeah for some reason i thought it would
all be controller based but i suppose it
is it is not it's too many uh
too many things um okay hold on next
[ __ ] something visual confirmation on
the airport great
that is we're oriented it's your turn
time to fly this bird
okay the first control on our training
list
is the yoke i still remember my first
instructor saying the yolk is like a
steering wheel
almost sure you can turn but you can
also
pitch where did it go what happened to
it
it controls the aileron that's
visibility
okay ailerons they allow the plane to
roll
and bank into turns so now i'm using my
controller again
despite it um okay try rolling to the
right
nice now let's see you level back out
really sensitive
which feels kind of nice i guess
of course controls the elevator
and the elevator affects the plane's
pitch right
sure yeah
your speed is decreasing yes
you could add more power you could add
more power
let's just pitch down pitch down
just like that your speed's picking up
again as the nose pitches down got it
cool as you level back out let's talk
about another control
the rudders at your feet okay
okay yeah rudder pedals control the
aircraft side to side movement
i didn't know any of this all right
on the ground those pedals are gonna
steer the plane left or right
i have no idea they properly align us
during turns
okay try him out and watch the plane's
nose skew to either side
how do i try them out are you going to
tell me how to do that aha
you know all right before we go on
let's bring the plane i don't i would
hate to be in this plane make sure your
dashboard is aligned three to four
inches below the horizon for a cruise
attitude
um i don't know how to tell that
the last thing we're gonna cover now is
the throttle
okay let's see what happens when you cut
all the power
uh uh okay i guess so what do we want to
do
decrease why have we done this
i don't feel good about this why is this
something that we've decided to do
surprise surprise our altitude is
decreasing yeah uh-huh it is yeah
okay this might be a good time for a
piloting psa
always keep an eye on your surroundings
because nobody likes a low-flying duck
i don't feel good about any of this love
all right let's go ahead and throttle
back up
i would love to yep let's uh thank you
is that a thing that they make you do in
pilot school
yeesh like that could be like a
well-known piloting thing and i just
um all right well i did it is it not
already
yeah it is increasing and as long as we
maintain the same attitude
our altitude will keep climbing too
okay you're really getting the hang of
your controls
before long you won't even need a
co-pilot great
i doubt that but thank you if you want
help with the radio
or checklist or simply flying the plane
i'll be here
okay you can pass me the controls when
you're ready to finish your session
or keep flying it is a great day after
all
i mean okay let's just like see i want
to see what happens to the text is when
i get a bit closer to the ground
training airspace you need to go back
fine
then i guess that i don't want to do
this then control alt x
all right i have control good job
i did it guess who didn't die
nailed it holy [ __ ] it's so
hot in here okay
um let's do
attitudes and training instruments and
then try fly home again
okay because i don't i can't keep doing
this for too long
it's so hot i don't need to land
i'll just quit it's whenever it's like
how do we land at the airport in
brisbane i'll just
exit the game cancel stream walk away
turn my pc off
you know if i if i just cut it out first
it doesn't matter
it's so sweaty hope you guys are all
doing okay you know
they said that they were gonna be
rotating power outages so
that's gonna be fun uh because too many
people are using the air conditionings
right now apparently so it's a good time
yeah it is a huge download this game's a
really big download it takes a long time
but it's got a lot in it
it's how it works you know today we're
talking about
attitudes of flight how your plane is
oriented relative to the horizon
okay if you look outside you can see the
cockpit
is just about four inches below the
horizon line
we're flying okay i guess yeah
this is the cruise attitude let's see
how it reads on your instruments
okay yes focus on instruments is going
to be control one
indicator as the name implies
it shows your current attitude the white
line is the horizon
with the sky above and the ground below
i don't like that this is called
attitude but i got it
orange element in the middle aligned
with the horizon that's your plane
cool just like we saw outside our
current
attitude reads pretty much straight and
level great
because the other spot now let's see how
much power the engine's generating
check your technology just in case
anyone it was that was true
we're pushing around 2300 revolutions
per minute where
did uh where did that attitude
and engine rpms translate to aircraft
performance
okay got it which leads us to your
airspeed indicator
okay yes i see
now last but not least check your
altimeter
to figure out your altitude thank you
for that
needle first that's how many thousands
of feet up you are
then on to the big needle for the
hundreds so not even a thousand
yeah with their current attitude and
power output we're holding a speed of
90 knots and a stable altitude of 6 000
feet
okay yeah that makes sense how would i
think it was less that makes sense
take the stick when you're ready because
i thought it was the
the that she said the small one and i
was seeing the small one that was
you see what i mean it looks like there
are three there not two but it's
actually just that's where it's scented
okay you want me to take the stick i'm
gonna fly slightly on the yoyo yes
just above the horizon it's so sensitive
about two inches
um how do i change the camera
is there a way to do that i want to
register you don't pitch up too much
where the ankle will be lift and without
enough lift
it'll stall
all right go full throttle and start
climbing
i don't know how to do that
from here glove
okay we're going back into the cockpit
we're looking down
and we're doing that and then we're
doing this because i don't know if you
can do it
see how it shows up on your attitude
indicator and tachometer
i'm going into your altimeter for
gaining altitude
i can't
okay before we go on let's get back to a
cruise attitude
ease up on the yoke and aim your nose
just below the horizon the word yogurt
back down to 2300 rpm
to to okay
okay great start by reducing your rpms
to 1800
i don't really drop the plane's nose
further below the horizon
okay okay okay i see i see i just look
at my rpms and i just go down
attitude the altitude is decreasing well
our speed is picking up
maybe like that okay great
why don't you get us back to a cruise
attitude and we'll hit the last part of
our lesson
maybe like a 70 and i'm back on a cruise
attitude i think
this is so much yeah oh no it needs more
you want 23.
there we go now that we know how to
cruise climb and descend
let's talk about the turn attitude
gently pull the yolk left or right to
start rolling the plane
like look i'm overwhelmed take a look
outside you can see how our attitude's
changed
i'm stressed and i don't know what's
happening but i'm also finding it very
pleasant you always want to keep your
turns
under 30 degrees disagree yeah you're
wrong about that
at the top of your attitude indicator
there's a series of notches representing
10 degrees each
use them to control your roll okay
so that's like gonna be like that notice
the more you turn
the more you need to pull back on the
yoke to maintain altitude
yes that's fine you'll need to do the
opposite roll and push at the same time
roll and push the more you know about
the main attitudes
disagree the closer you get to that
pilot's state of mind that seemed like
that keep practicing
and whenever you're done
don't feel good about this lesson at all
she said push but then i go just down
you know and i don't think that we want
that
it's fine i'm not out here trying to do
any roles i just want to fly hot
thanks i've got control now well done
just want to fly home
just not trying to roll a plane i was
actually when i started i was like i
would be able to roll planes
i'm gonna be able to do flips i'm gonna
do barrel rolls it's gonna be sick
and then um i like left an altitude
and stole the plane in the sky so
shall we shall we shall we leave this
get me back to the
can i go home uh how
how to uh yep
i'm gonna try and fly again i'm probably
not ready for it
of course i don't have a joystick i'm
not out here playing flight sims
come on go back
okay let's try this again
the departure i put was k-l-a-x clax
uh pne i don't know what it is ybn
so is what else am i supposed to do here
who knows really
sure yeah okay okay
it's just so much it's just so much
you know
can i get like what is the fastest plane
you have
ah
does seven hour endurance is that gonna
cause problems for me
am i not gonna make this
i think this is probably not gonna work
uh if the range is
and then how long's the flight
who'd have thought this is a bigger
pilot as a complicated job
okay i think i need probably well none
of those are gonna work what's a
turbo prop nope i'm just gonna go with a
747
because that's what always happens when
i do fly hunt
you know i always usually fly home on a
747
so let's i know it works
can i like pull that [ __ ] everything up
like i don't
it's just so many questions
oh man
i don't feel like i should touch any of
this i don't think
any of this should be a thing that i
press at all so we're just gonna
sure yep yep
okay um
nope that's friends okay i guess
it's i don't you know
i'm not gonna make it uh i thought that
that was like i know there's a setting
somewhere where you can speed up flights
and i was like can i just do that when
i'm already on the flight
or is that also not going to work
well i got rid of fuel because i gave it
too much fuel and then i was like trying
to balance it out do i need more fuel
okay great i don't have enough fuel
excellent
i mean i'm not going to make this anyway
it's going to take 18 real-time hours
so i do have some fuel we just don't
have enough apparently stop yelling at
me
i will say one thing that sucks about
streaming a game that i
am very openly um admitting to
not knowing anything about is that
people on the internet will still get
angry at you for not knowing anything
about it like i said it from the jump
i'm still gonna get [ __ ] stupid [ __ ]
i'm like hey
let people not know anything about
things and enjoy them anyway you know
it's okay but it is gonna happen
it's fine
you are correct bear insurance how dare
i not know how to fly a plane it is
a problem yes god it's so [ __ ] hot
well i don't want to complete the
training because that would take too
long and it's too hot
like i have a series of obstacles here
i basically can't play pc games right
now it has to be uh
unless i can be really far away like if
i can like just be all the way back here
that's fine then i can be really far
from my pc but this game requires a
keyboard and a mouse also
so that doesn't work
oh it's so hot am i finding the game
enjoyable um i mean i've not really
played it i don't feel like but sure
yes i've been you know having fun with
the
small amount of chaos that hasn't chewed
oh my god just melting just melting
are you sure broken horizon because
microsoft told me that i should play
with
a controller and keyboard and mouse los
angeles tower boeing alpha sierra
747 ready had run way too far right
departure all right well the internet
told me this isn't going to work because
i don't have enough fuel
uh okay
cool yep checklist
basic controls ai control
did i automate it there i don't have to
take off
right yeah
all right we can we do it i just want to
go home
okay so fuel i didn't think i got rid of
it that's exactly what it looked like
right
it's 50 did i did i need to increase
this like i don't want to make it too
heavy though i was worried like that was
a thing
but did i i feel like i didn't do that
uh
you're right i didn't do the pilot
speech i'm sorry
like this is a thing that i feel like i
shouldn't have [ __ ] with because it
didn't have that already and i don't
know that i should have done that
um nav log
why is that even there
okay what's how do i please everything
go away everything go away
i'm trying to close all of you please go
away
uh okay what have we done here oh look
at us
yeah we're doing
it do i have to do anything i i set it
to automate it
okay this is i'm took the pressure off
of b if this crashes
747 frequency change it's not my fault
it's not my fault everything's fine
it's great we did it okay what else is
in here objectives
this is so elaborate and also i should
mention the bravo airspace
all of his functions um obviously i
can't play it on ultrawide when
streaming it
but uh so this would all be stuff that i
could lay out on this like well my
monitor is actually super ultra wide not
just ultrawide
um yeah but i i again i'm i'm not the
target market for this game uh
i'll leave that that up there because
i'm into it
the sound is really good too but it's
just like this is a lot of [ __ ] menu
and a lot of a lot of customization
uh okay what does this do oh bro
there was one time that i flew home
or the other way i actually don't
remember but i had sun almost the entire
flight because the plane was flying in
the direction of the sunset
so it like it was maybe like two hours
of dock
um yeah why is that from donald trump
because i already said it to that baby
oh if we frozen we have frozen
i'm pretty sure that's what happened
just have a little unfreeze it's fine
just gotta get home
it's definitely a lot ashley it's
definitely a lot i feel like i could i
could run
if i wanted to obviously can't do it
when the game pros
but uh that is the thing that people
have been saying
um with this release is that there have
been issues with it um
freezing and a couple of crashes and
massive blood screens
do you all not have fans i mean it's hot
because when streaming i
don't use a fan because that would be
bad audio for you
so be appreciative did it start again
my altitude yes
okay so how to get home faster
is my next question
i know i can speed this up somewhere
oh no that's the toolbar this is this is
dope this is super cool
um but how do i do it you know how do i
how do i
we already know where we're traveling to
oh
that is exactly what i want to do
uh my pc tempo is thankfully not an
issue i said this before but it's liquid
cool my
i'm fine it's uh
when i compare my my i mean my pc is
blowing out hot air but like when i
compare my pc temp
to what i feel like my temperature is
i'm like it's fine
it's doing okay i'm dying
a wind muff on the mic should cancel fan
noise right absolutely
not dear god no fan noises is always
gonna
be a problem um so i don't have a fan on
me because then yeah it would be
useless listening to it uh sure
this is not i said approach [ __ ]
this is not what i wanted at all this
this approach seems quite far off
boeing 747. but you know i do have to
stop because i'm it's too hot
i'm not doing any of this we can just
take that
excessive damage hang on hang on again
you got to give me
you got to give me daylight it's got to
be i would like to be able to see
there we go this is not what i wanted at
all
can i um just like lift the plane up
though
can i just not land no the ai's already
doing it
if i
turn everything off and i go rogue with
the plane
yes this is basically what i wanted i
can't wait to crash this [ __ ]
okay okay let's go let's go
we're gonna we're going up i'm trying to
oh it doesn't like that
oh boy okay
come on buddy oh [ __ ]
it's not gonna happen i'm gonna what i'm
gonna do by wanting to visit brisbane
because i'm not [ __ ] with my throttle
right now is actually crash into
brisbane
um so that's obama but
i i don't know how to um
increase the throttle from the outside
view yet we'll figure it out
there's time to figure it out look i
can't [ __ ] do this anymore it's so
[ __ ] sweaty i'm so sorry
i would have loved to have but i
basically just again can't stream right
now unless i can be really far back so
hey here's a little preview of this game
that i'm very bad at simulator rather
not a simulator person it's okay i'm not
using a joystick i don't have one as i
am
not a flight simulator person uh this is
the first one that i've ever had any
interest in which is again mostly
because of
the realism it looks very cool um i know
bruce is streaming i will be joining him
quite soon
i'm going to go to bruce's stream so
i'll do that soon
yep game's mad complicated but i'm into
it
i'll definitely do it again i like
learning
i am using a controller
that is what i'm using um but it does
it's it's complicated [ __ ] it's way too
hot i'm sorry guys
can't stream right now it's too hot but
hopefully this uh
terrible very confused chaotic preview
in which
uh all i wanted to do was see my home
city but instead what i did was
crash a boeing uh
into my home city basically the opposite
of what i wanted
um was at least fun to watch so i
appreciate it
i will see you guys next time
you